there are millions of people in the
world using sign language and a big part
of them are in China and right now we
know the growth we're faster so for my
video I since I write high technology
happened this project is a sign language
translator it translates from one sign
language to another it helps the hearing
and the Deaf communicate
Nihao imagine a a deaf person walking
into a doctor's office the doctor is a
regular doctor probably can't speak in
sign language hello my name is dr. Wong
what is hurting you but the patient
wants to communicate with the doctor
today they'd have to use a maybe writing
and it would be very artificial but here
with this technology they could use
signing and the doctor would be able to
understand that that signing
so another scenario is and information
killed hello how can I help you and
rather than say the person seeking
information at that kiosk in death
imagine if the person that the
information kiosk was was death which
way is the taxi stand now a hearing
person who come to that kiosk and to ask
questions of their death person and the
system could help them communicate with
the deaf person and vice versa please go
outside the terminal and make a left
great thank you so I think the gleason
about these illusions people coming from
totally different disciplines and from
the different organizations so I really
learned a lot from it so one of the
things that we're doing with this
project is working with the deaf
community directly we're working with a
school in China for the death and
they've helped us understand better that
is quite an isolated feeling in debt
even today what overwhelmingly you feel
when you see it working is a certain
magic but you know that there's more
work to do but you can see the potential
there that one day this is going to be
something that is going to transform
lives
you